-Our next guest is the reigning
CMA Female Vocalist of the Year.
Performing "Diamondback"
from her album
"29: Written in Stone,"
please welcome Carly Pearce!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Never been all that wrapped
up in shiny swimming pools ♪
♪ Those material
kinda lies they tell ♪
♪ Life looks oh so well
from the outside in ♪
♪ Honeymoons don't end ♪
♪ No, what I thought
I wanted let me down ♪
♪ But I don't want it now ♪
♪ Keep the house,
keep the truck ♪
♪ Go downtown, get too drunk ♪
♪ Kiss a one-night stand with
a butterfly on her back ♪
♪ Take the bed
where you used to lie ♪
♪ Keep the friends
I never liked ♪
♪ And the "happy ever after"
welcome mat ♪
♪ But you ain't gonna get
this diamond back ♪
♪ No, never, ever gettin'
♪ You can keep the dog
and the Cadillac ♪
♪ But you ain't gonna get
this diamond back ♪
♪ Well, I guess
I'll just burn that dress ♪
♪ All those fairy tales
can go straight to hell ♪
♪ Don't need you no more,
with this ♪
♪ 24 carats that I'm wearin' ♪
♪ No, I don't care if you ♪
♪ Keep the house,
keep the truck ♪
♪ Go downtown, get too drunk ♪
♪ Kiss a one-night stand with
a butterfly on her back ♪
♪ Take the bed
where you used to lie ♪
♪ Keep the friends
I never liked ♪
♪ And the "happy ever after"
welcome mat ♪
♪ But you ain't gonna get
this diamond back ♪
♪ No, never, ever gettin'
♪ You can keep the dog
and the Cadillac ♪
♪ But you ain't gonna get
this diamond back ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, what I thought
I wanted let me down ♪
♪ But who's laughing now? ♪
♪ Keep the house,
keep the truck ♪
♪ Go downtown, get too drunk ♪
♪ Kiss a one-night stand with
a butterfly on her back ♪
♪ Yeah, take the bed
where you used to lie ♪
♪ Keep the friends
I never liked ♪
♪ And the "happy ever after"
welcome mat ♪
♪ But you ain't gonna get
this diamond back ♪
♪ No, never, ever gettin'
♪ It's in a pawnshop
next to the laundromat ♪
♪ You ain't gonna
get this diamond back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]